[Music]
you walk alone into a room and you find
a chessboard each of the 64 squares has
a coin sitting on top of it and taking a
step back this is gonna be one of those
classic prisoner puzzles where a
strangely math obsessed warden offers
you and a fellow inmate a chance for
freedom but only if the two of you solve
some elaborate scheme that they've laid
out in this case what they've done is
carefully turned over each of the coins
to be heads or tails according to
whatever pattern they want it to be and
then they show you a key they put that
key inside one of the chessboard squares
each square is a secret compartment or
something like that so you know where
the key is
and the goal is going to be to get
prisoner number 2 to also know where the
key is but the only thing that the
warden allows you to do before you leave
the room is to turn over one and only
one of these coins at that point you
walk out your fellow prisoner walks in
and with no information other than the
set of heads and tails that they're
looking at which you've only barely
tweaked they're supposed to deduce where
the key is hidden potentially winning
freedom for the both of you as is
typical with these puzzles the two of
you can strategize ahead of time if you
want but you won't know what the
specific layout of heads and tails is
and moreover the warden can listen in on
your strategy and do their absolute best
to thwart it with some adversarial
arrangement of the coins and the key so
I first heard about this puzzle over
dinner conversation actually at a
wedding and it just totally sucked me in
I remember the drive home was maybe
three hours and I think my mind was
glued to the topic of flipping coins and
encoding state that whole time
but the puzzle sticks with you even
after that after I solved it I fell into
these two surprisingly interesting
rabbit holes one was to prove that the
challenge is actually impossible if you
vary the set up a little bit maybe
making it a 6x6 chess board or maybe
removing one of the squares and to give
you a little sense for where that rabbit
hole leads this video is going to end
with an especially pleasing way to paint
the corners of a four dimensional cube
the other rabbit hole was to work out
how closely you can connect the solution
of this puzzle with error correction
which is a super important topic in
computer science and information theory
the idea is that when computers send and
store data the messiness of the real
world inevitably flips a bit now and
then and that can completely change how
the data is read so error correcting
codes are a way to add a shockingly
small amount of information to a message
that makes it possible for the receiver
to identify both when there is an error
and more impressively precisely how to
fix it
it turns out that the intuition for
solving this puzzle is essentially the
same as the intuition behind these
things called hamming codes which are
one of the earliest examples of highly
efficient error correction which is all
to say time spent mulling over this
problem is not as useless as you might
think it is now you and I aren't
actually going to go through the
solution here instead I filmed a video
all about that on stand-up maths with
Matt Parker who I'm sure many of you
recognize from his combined YouTube and
stand-up in book Fame we each talk
through our thought process and solving
it and it's good fun because there are
multiple ways of looking at it instead
what I want to do with you here is take
a more global view of every possible
strategy for this puzzle and bring you
with me down that first rabbit hole of
proving why certain variations
necessarily leave room for the warden to
thwart you no matter how clever you are
the proof itself is one of those
satisfying moments where you shift
perspective and it reveals the solution
and the whole context leading up to it
is a nice chance to practice reasoning
about higher dimensional objects as a
way to draw conclusions about
information and data plus it does more
to help you appreciate the solution to
the original puzzle when you can see how
it is in a sense almost impossible
[Music]
where to start what we want is some kind
of visualization for what it even means
to solve this puzzle and to build up to
the general case let's not things down
to the simplest case that we can that
still has any kind of meaning to it two
squares two coins and two possibilities
for where the key is one way that you
could solve this is to simply let the
second coin communicate where the key is
if its tail's it means the key is in the
left square if it's heads
it means the keys in the right square
not a big deal right it's one bit of
information so when you need to change
that coin you can flip it but if you
don't need to change it you can just
flip the other coin first things first
let's stop thinking about these as heads
and tails and start thinking of them as
ones and zeros that's much easier to do
math with then you can think of these
pairs of coins as a set of coordinates
where each of the four possible states
that the board can be in sit at the
corners of a unit square like this this
might feel like a silly thing to do when
we already know how to solve this case
but it's a good warm-up for turning the
larger cases into a kind of geometry
notice flipping one of the coins moves
you along an edge of the square since
it's only changing one of the
coordinates our strategy of letting that
second coin encode the key location
could be drawn by associating the bottom
two corners where the y-coordinate is 0
with the key is under square 0 state
which means those top two corners are
associated with the key is under square
one state so think about what it means
for our solution to actually work it
means that no matter where you start if
you're forced to take a step along an
edge force to flip one of the coins you
can always guarantee that you end up in
whichever of these two regions you want
to
[Music]
now the question is what does it look
like for a bigger chess board the next
simplest case would be three squares
three coins and three possibilities for
where the key is this gives us eight
possible states that the coin can be in
and playing the same game that we did
before interpreting these states as
coordinates it brings us up into
three-dimensional space with each state
sitting at the corner of a unit cube the
usefulness in a picture like this is
that it gives a very vivid meaning to
the idea of turning over one of the
coins every time you flip a coin you're
walking along the edge of a cube now
what would it mean for you and your
fellow inmate to have a strategy for
this puzzle when every prisoner too
walks into that room they need to be
able to associate the state that they're
looking at three bits basically with one
of three possible squares we're already
thinking very visually so let's
associate those squares with colors
maybe red four squares zero green four
square one and blue four square two in
this conception coming up with a
strategy any possible strategy is the
same thing as coloring each of the eight
corners of the cube either red green or
blue so for example let's say you
colored the whole cube red well I don't
know if you'd call this a strategy
exactly but it would correspond with
always guessing that the key is
undersquare zero let's say instead your
strategy was to add the first two coins
together and use that as an encoding for
the key location well then the cube
would look like this what's kind of fun
is we can count how many total
strategies exist with three choices for
the color of each vertex and eight total
vertices we get 3 to the power eight or
if you're comfortable letting your mind
straight to the thought of painting a 64
dimensional cube you can have fun
thinking about the sense in which there
are 64 to the 2 to the 64 total possible
strategies for the original puzzle this
is the size of the haystack when you're
looking for the needle
another attempt for the three square
case might look like taking zero times
coin 0 plus 1 times coin 1 plus 2 times
coin 2 and then reduce that sum mod 3 if
you need to overrun stand up maths Matt
and I both talked about trying a version
of this for the 64 square case and why
it works decently well for a random
arrangement of coins but why it's
ultimately doomed from our view over
here it just looks like one more way to
color the cube but it's worth taking a
moment to walk through some of those
corners let's say that you get into the
room and all three coins are set to
tails so it's like you're starting at
the corner zero zero zero if you were to
flip coin zero that doesn't change the
sum so it takes you to another red
corner if you flipped coin one it
increases the sum by one so it takes you
to a green corner and flipping coin two
takes you up to two which looks like a
blue corner the fact that you always
have access to whichever color you want
is a reflection of the fact that this
strategy will always win if this is the
corner that you're starting on on the
other hand let's say that you started at
zero one zero well in that case flipping
coin zero takes you to another green
corner since it doesn't change the sum
but flipping either coin 1 or coin to
happen to take you to a red corner
there's simply no way to get to a blue
corner
basically what's happening here is that
you have the options to subtract one by
turning off coin one or two add two by
turning on coin two and if you're
working mod three those are both
actually the same operation but that
means that there's no way to change the
sum to be to an adversarial warden who
knows your strategy could start with
this configuration put the key under
square two and call it done but even
without thinking about sums mod three or
anything like that
whatever the implementation details you
can see this in our picture manifested
as a corner that has two neighbors of
the same color if you don't have a
bird's eye view of all possible
strategies when you find that any
specific one of them just doesn't work
you're left to wonder okay maybe there's
a sneaky clever strategy that I just
haven't thought of yet but when we're
thinking about colors on the cube you're
naturally led to an interesting
combinatorial question is there some way
that you can paint this so that the
three neighbors of any given vertex
always represent red green and blue
maybe it seems bizarre even convoluted
to go from a puzzle with chess boards
and coins to talking about painting
corners of a cube but this is actually a
much more natural step than you might
expect I have talked with a lot of
people about this puzzle and what I love
is that many of the experienced problem
solvers immediately jump unprompted to
talking about coloring the corners of a
cube as if it's a kind of de-facto
language for this puzzle and it really
is thinking about binary strings as
vertices of a high dimensional cube with
bit flips corresponding to edges that
actually comes up a lot especially in
coding theory like the error correction
stuff I referenced earlier
what's more you often hear
mathematicians talk about coloring
things as a way to describe partitioning
them into distinct sets if you've ever
heard of that hilariously enormous
number grams constant for example the
problem where that came up was also
phrased in terms of assigning colors to
a high dimensional cube so in that case
colors were given two pairs of vertices
instead of individual ones the point is
analyzing how to color a high
dimensional cube is more of a
transferable skill than you might expect
so to our question can you make it so
that every vertex has a red a green and
a blue neighbor remember this is the
same thing as having an encoding for key
locations so that you're always one flip
away from communicating whichever
location you want to would actually be
enlightening if you pause the video and
try this now it's like a weird
three-dimensional variant of a Sudoku
very similar to Sudokus in fact in the
sense that you want certain subsets to
be filled with all three possible States
for example you might start by painting
one of the corners and arbitrary color
let's say red and so you know that it's
three neighbors need to be red green and
blue doesn't really matter how you do it
and then maybe we move to the red
neighbor and say that the other two
adjacencies need to be green and blue
maybe we do it like this but at least
how I've drawn it here you're stuck you
are unable to choose a correct color for
the next two can you see why what I'd
like to share is a lovely little
argument that explains not only why this
will never work in three dimensions but
also why it can't work in any dimension
that's not a power of two the idea is
that the symmetry in the property that
we're looking at will end up implying
that there have to be an equal number of
red green and blue vertices but that
would mean that there's eight thirds of
each which is not possible and before I
go on pause see if you can think of a
way to solidify that intuition it's a
fun exercise in turning a vague instinct
into a solid proof
[Music]
all right you ready one way to do this
is to imagine a process where you go
through each corner and you count how
many of its neighbors are a particular
color say red so each step here we're
looking at the three neighbors of a
given vertex counting up the red ones
and adding that to a total tally for
this specific coloring that count came
out to be 12 but if we had the property
that we wanted every corner would have
exactly one red neighbor so that count
should be eight on the other hand every
red corner is counted exactly three
times once for each instance where it's
somebody's neighbor so that final tally
has to be three times the total number
of red corners so you know it's simple
find a coloring where eight thirds of
the corners are red isn't that nice
counting how many times some corner has
a red neighbor is the same as counting
how many times a red corner has some
neighbor and that's actually enough to
get us a contradiction what's also nice
is that this argument immediately
generalizes to higher dimensions think
about solving the chessboard puzzle with
n squares again the puzzle is to
associate each arrangement of coins with
some state some possible location for
the key and the goal is to make it so
that the arrangements that you can get
to with one flip of a coin represent all
possible states all possible places the
warden might have hidden that key even
if you can't visualize most
higher-dimensional cubes we can still
talk about things like vertices of such
a cube and their neighbors basically as
a way to describe bitstrings
and the ones which are one bit flip away
really there's just two relevant facts
you need to know if you're standing at
one of these vertices you have n
distinct neighbors and the total number
of vertices is 2 to the N one for each
bit string of length N and from here you
can play the same game that we did in
three dimensions you can go through each
corner and count how many red neighbors
it has if it's possible to do the
coloring we want this sum should be 2 to
the N one for each vertex
on the other hand each red corner is
counted once for each of its neighbors
so that means that we need to end up
with n times the total number of red
corners since that left-hand side is a
power of two the right-hand side also
has to be a power of two which could
only ever happen if n itself is some
smaller power of two so for example if
we were in four dimensions or sixty-four
dimensions there is no contradiction
it's at the very least possible to
evenly divide the vertices among the
different colours to be clear that is
not the same thing as saying that
necessarily is a solution for the power
of two case it's just that it can't be
ruled out yet to me this is completely
delightful just by imagining coloring
the corners of a cube and then counting
how many there are you can conclude that
no possible strategy no matter how
clever you are can work in all of the
cases for this chessboard puzzle if the
number of squares isn't a power of two
so even though it might seem to make it
easier if you knock off a couple squares
or reduce the size of the board it
actually makes the task hopeless it also
means that the solution to this puzzle
which I'll point you to in a moment can
be viewed as a particularly symmetric
way to color the corners of a high
dimensional cube in a way that's
disallowed in most dimensions and if
you're curious I just couldn't resist
showing this explicitly for a four
dimensional cube so in the same way that
you can take a 3d cube and kind of
squish it down into two dimensions maybe
with a little perspective and get the
same graph structure for how the
vertices and edges are all connected we
can do the same thing projecting a
four-dimensional cube into 3-dimensional
space and still go to complete view for
how all of the vertices and edges are
hooked together if you wanted to try
your hand at a weird sort of
four-dimensional cousin of a Sudoku you
could pause right now and try to figure
out how to color these vertices in such
a way that each of the four neighbors of
anyone represent all four different
colors
using essentially the same computation
that solves the chessboard puzzle for
the Foursquare case I can get the
computer to explicitly draw that out for
us
and at this point when you're hopefully
burning to know what the actual solution
is I'd like you to hop on over to stand
up maths where Matt and I show you how
it works if any of you are somehow not
yet familiar with stand-up maths it is
one of my favorite channels run by one
of my favorite people
so please do immediately subscribe once
you land over there I promise you're in
for quite a few delights with everything
else he has to offer
before explaining it he and I simply
walk through what it looks like for us
to actually perform the solution and as
we do I really want you to try thinking
of the solution yourself and to predict
what it is that we're doing before we
tell you and if you're curious about the
connection with hamming codes and error
correction
I'm definitely game to make a video on
that just let me know in the comments
I've been told that as far as motivating
puzzles go not everyone is as interested
in symmetrical ways to paint a 64
dimensional cube as I am but reliable
data transmission come on I think we can
all agree that that's universally sexy
[Music]
[Music]